i thought because there are some changes
now i'd just like to make some
additional uh kind of forward views
about what's going to happen and then uh
patrick is going to add a few as well
the first is just to say something about
the omicron wave the omicron wave is
still high
and if you look around the uk
we're still in places we're still
between 1 and 20 and 1 in 25 people have
got
omicron if they were tested according to
ns data which is slightly backward
looking now the rates are coming down
but this is still a very common
infection
and it is important to uh view the next
period
when we will still have testing all the
way up to april
and which
changes are happening in fact in steps
people think about this as one big step
this is a gradual steady change
over a period of time as the rates are
going down and as we head into spring
and i think it's important to understand
that context this is not a sudden
everything stops this is a steady move
just as the good news is things are
going down as we head into spring we do
have to accept that the respiratory
season next winter and in subsequent
winters these light is combined covered
whatever variants are circulating there
flu and all the other respiratory
problems so
we expect the winters to be tricky even
in the absence of significant new
variants and we again the vaccination
program that jccvi will consider
will take that into account
now the implications of this are
as we look at the next weeks we still
have high rates of omicron
and
i would urge people in terms of public
health advice and this is very much the
government's position i'm
that people should still if they have
covid
uh try to prevent other people getting
it and that means self-isolating so that
is the public health advice it would
have been the public health advice and
will be the public health advice for
multiple other diseases if you had no
reverse we would give exactly the same
public health advice so this is standard
public health advice for a significant
and highly transmissible infection we
must have three things we must have good
surveillance as the prime minister said
to ensure that when new variants start
to take off when we start to see new
surges we know where they are and we can
respond in a targeted and rapid way to
make sure we deal with them before they
cause significant problems for
individuals and for the nhs
we must have the capacity rapidly to
step up
uh in terms of what we're doing and we
must be able to protect the most
vulnerable and those really are the
critical things that we need to maintain
even beyond the uh this next few weeks a
few weeks into
the rest of this year and the rest of
the way that we continue to manage this
epidemic patrick was going to expand a
bit on the issues uh in particular
around variation
yeah thank you so
very clear this pandemic is not over and
it's carrying on around the world and
we're not out of it here yet
the virus is continuing to evolve
so
every variant is an
evolution and
the virus has got a lot of room to
evolve
and it will continue to do so quite fast
probably for the next couple of years
those changes
will alter the properties of the virus
there is no guarantee that the next
variant
is
as
reduced severity as omicron
it could be the same it could be more
could be less
so as it evolves what it's trying to do
is transmit more readily to grow so that
could be because it has got intrinsic
transmissibility advantage
or it escapes immunity
and the change in severity
is a random by-product
so we expect there to be further
variance and they could be more severe
as chris has said if you look at omicron
actually
with the immunity we've got in the
population the level of severe illness
and death has been dramatically reduced
and that's the reason across the world
people are beginning to release measures
it's not just here everyone is beginning
to release measures
but in order to do that safely
there are some things that need to be in
place
the first is it's absolutely essential
to have
a way of detecting it a good
surveillance system
and we're lucky that we have a very good
surveillance system in this country the
ons study
which is a way of picking up across the
population both at a national level and
at a regional level and in different age
groups
what is happening and that detection
system is going to be vital
the second thing that's important
is being able to respond quickly
so the resilience and the ability to
ramp up is absolutely crucial and that
doesn't mean ramp up over months if
something goes wrong you need to be able
to ramp up very quickly
just remember how quickly omicron took
off
that tells you you've got a couple of
weeks to get things back in action
so once you take things off
it's going to be important to know how
quickly you can put them back on again
and to get them back in shape
in time to be able to deal with it